while there are many situations in elden
ring where i think to myself why am i
doing this none bothered me more than
after i killed scar scourge radon it is
an awesome boss fight and the second
phase may go down as one of my favorite
moments in gaming history
but before during and after the fight i
couldn't help but be a little confused
pretty much just like all of elden
ringlor entering the castle to hear a
choir of radon's men singing in unison
to celebrate a festival of champions to
honor their now mentally insane general
in hopes that he can receive a warrior's
death made me think wow this guy must be
[ __ ] awesome and then his awesomeness
is clearly confirmed with his own cut
scene in elden ring which is pretty rare
that tells us that after his fight with
melania he had been infected with the
scarlet rot and he now roams of what
remains of the caled wilds eating
corpses and howling at the sky like a
dog but how long has verdan been roaming
around in the sand well the timeline
can't be confirmed but it was at least
an age ago and an age ago an elden ring
could mean anything who knows how long
all of these people live could be
thousands of years could be hundreds of
years could be last week who knows but
it's at least enough time for both of
his feet to be scraped off while
dragging his feet through the sand an
interesting thing to look at is the
story trailer of elden rang he has his
feet in the trailer but when we fight
him they're gone he has no toes and
radon has to rely on his scrawny horse
to ride him around in our fight with him
now you're probably thinking this guy is
absolutely massive definitely goes to
the gym at 5 a.m every day so how is
this scrawny horse even able to hold
radon up let alone ride him around well
renault is a sorcerer he's able to
control gravity and hovers slightly
above his trusty steed just enough to
not crush the horse and by the way the
horse's name is leonard and according to
some item descriptions of radons radon
loved leonard so much that when radon
was younger he started to study gravity
spells in order to keep writing him as
he got older stronger and bigger radon
was taught his sorceries in the caled
town of celia and just looking at these
buildings while most of them are
destroyed definitely were not big enough
to house radon that tells us that radon
used to be much smaller in his younger
days likely due to his demigod status
radon grew rapidly in size as he got
older so this man legit learned how to
control gravity so he could keep riding
the horse he loved so much like come on
that's that's [ __ ] adorable and
knowing this i didn't want to kill ronan
anymore i'm not sipping that hard for
this blue doll yet but wait a second why
does ronnie need us to kill radon at all
well with his gravity powers radon can
control the stars above yeah radon is so
powerful that he can stop the stars
above from moving now he's either trying
to stop ronnie from fulfilling her
destiny which requires the stars to move
for lots of reasons that we could go
over in another video or he's trying to
stop beans like the falling star beasts
and other crazy astral like scary
monsters from crashing down to the lands
between and you know what likely both
are true to be honest but stopping these
alien beings would make the most sense
since radon was taught gravity magic
from an all bastard lord who also fell
from the sky in a meteor it's possible
radon was warned by his albastar master
that something scary is coming to the
lands between something that wants to
destroy the greater will and the golden
order which is apparently also from
space again that's all stuff for another
video that the lore in this game is so
confusing radon is a demigod born from
ratagon and ranala now if you didn't
know this already ratagon is queen
marika they're the same thing so that
makes him a demigod however radon
idolizes the first elden lord godfrey
going as far as branding his own red
main lion armor after godfrey's lion
companion sirosh so needless to say
rodon is a very very good boy to the
golden order so it would make sense for
him to want to stop ronnie whose entire
being is a spirit who is going to
completely eat everything that is and
isn't in the lands between and start
completely over meaning no more golden
order no more greater will no more lands
between and no more leonard so all of
these are a likely reason ragan holds
back the stars basically what i'm saying
is radon is sick nasty with it like
super powerful when the elden ring was
shattered by queen merica melania
challenged radon to obtain the power of
his great rune now let's go back to the
story trailer again radon allows melania
to put her prosthetic arm back on before
attacking her showing that he still
values the honor of battle even during a
free-for-all war to obtain powers from a
shattered elden ring so while fighting
melania he is still holding back the
stars above with gravity magic at the
same time melania then proceeds to nuke
the continent of caled with her scarlet
rot and that is still not enough to kill
radon or stop him from controlling the
stars so radon while going bat [ __ ]
insane after being infected with the
scarlet rod still holds back the stars
and still hovers himself above his horse
that is awesome and adorable like i love
radon even during our boss fight with
him every time he does an aoe attack he
hides leonard in the sand to protect him
again he's doing all of this while
scarlet rot eats away at his brain so a
lot of the old general radon that we
have heard so much about is still in
there somewhere and even after his
infection his loyal soldiers offer a
festival champions for the strongest
around to try their luck fighting
against radon just so he can have an
honorable death i don't know about you
guys but after learning all of this
information i didn't feel like the main
character anymore i didn't even feel
like a good guy anymore i mean i know
we're giving radon what he wants which
is an honorable death but we're also
stopping him from holding back something
that he clearly did not want to come to
the lands between and he was holding it
up in the sky for hundreds if not
thousands of years that is some
seriously hardcore dedication to
continue to hold back something in space
while your brain is literally being
eaten away by a rapidly spreading
disease so from now on every time i walk
into the radon boss fight i know that
i'm fighting the main character of eldon
ring the hero of elder ring at least in
my eyes i'm just some random tarnish
who's died to a pack of [ __ ] goats
twice at this point
so i'm putting radon down not for this
blue chick but to honor an absolute
badass warrior that just wanted to
protect his horse thank you all for
watching the video hit the like button
subscribe if you want to see you all in
the next one take care